in his first known trip outside of
moscow since invading ukraine vladimir
putin met with his closest ally the
president of belarus
alexander lukashenko blamed russia's
massacre of civilians in bucha on
british special forces and reiterated
belarus's support for putin's so-called
special operation
since the start of the war belarus has
allowed russia to launch attacks from
its territory but the position of the
belarusian president and the belarusian
people appear starkly different the
people do not support him at all
this belarusian software engineer is now
in ukraine fighting with the ukrainian
military part of an entire battalion of
belarusian volunteers one of their goals
to restore the reputation of their
people it was a big shame for
personally for me that
russian tanks invade ukraine from the
territory of my country for their
actions he and others would face long
prison sentences if they ever returned
home to belarus that is as long as
lukashenko remains in power position now
is very fragile on that one hand he
doesn't have support of most of bill
resident people
this belarusian opposition leader lives
in exile her husband was arrested while
trying to run for president in 2020 so
she took his place and lost
sparking mass protests and allegations
of voter fraud
lukashenko clung to power with the
backing of putin but his support for
russia's botched invasion of ukraine may
have sealed his fate he
thought that he is on the side of
strong russia his future is under huge
question
some experts believe lukashenko's
tenuous position is why he's resisted
russian pressure to become directly
involved by engaging in the ground war
directly
belarus can set and train dynamics that
can in fact lead to popular unrest which
could indeed lead to the overthrow of
the belarusian regime itself and with
russia's military focused on ukraine an
uprising in belarus would be more
difficult to quash
spurring speculation if putin loses in
ukraine his ally lukashenko europe's
last soviet era dictator could be next
jeff sample global news toronto